Yeah, one of the things that,...
...the question of what's uniquely human is actually a big one.
Depending on who you ask, you might get really different answers.
If I had to put my money on something that was actually uniquely human,...
...it seems, in some funny way, to be our motivation to actually...
...interact with others, in a funny way.
And what I mean by this is that generally, if you look at any human anywhere,...
...if they're hanging out with other humans,...
...they're often doing something with or showing something to another individual.
So, you see something cool and you say, "Oh! Hey, look at this cool thing."
And to psychologists, this is this process of reference.
Traits of sharing, referring to information out there in the world.
And it seems like, in other primates,...
...even though you think this is kind of a simple ability, they seem to lack...
...at least the motivation to do this.
This leads to the fact that they don't have the kind of communication that we have.
The things like language with nouns that can kind of point to things out there in the world.
They also don't seem to share their own desires and intentions with others,...
...which leads to a lack of kind of cooperation in a lot of domains.
So, if I had to put my money on what was uniquely human,...
...I'd go with the kind of motivation to share information with others.